now the US has hit three million
coronavirus cases and now accounts for
about a quarter of Cova deaths globally
nevertheless Donald Trump is still
trying to convince everybody that
Washington is leading the fight against
the virus but Canada Mexico and even the
EU don't seem to be convinced as calleb
Maupin explains over 130,000 Americans
have died from kovat 19 and the number
of those infected across America has
surpassed the 3 million mark but that
hasn't stopped us leaders from bragging
and claiming that the USA is the leader
globally in fighting the virus I think
the world is looking at us as a leader
and covin 19 we show cases 99% of which
are totally harmless results that no
other country can show because no other
country is testing but we have now the
rest of the world isn't buying that one
bit the USA's neighbor to the north
Canada says they're doing a better job
fighting the virus than the United
States is we were able to control the
virus better than many of our allies
particularly including our neighbor
non-essential travel between the USA and
Canada has been shut down since March
now some people wanted to open up again
on July 21st but most Canadians say they
want to keep the Americans out Canadian
Prime Minister skipped his meeting with
Donald Trump and the Mexican president
earlier this week the reason he gave
safety concerns of course but it looks
like Canadian Prime Minister wasn't
missed at least by Trump gushed over his
southern counterpart it's been a
profound privilege to have you with us
today and it's a profound privilege to
have you as my friend we've had a great
relationship right from the beginning
the Mexican people are incredible they
upheld our highest values God family and
country now you might remember that a
big beautiful wall was a central plank
of Donald Trump's campaign
well things have taken an interest
turn since then local residents on the
Arizona US border have been blocking the
roads to keep Americans out of Mexico
and Mexico actually installed
disinfection tunnels for travelers from
the United States none of this has
knocked any wind out of America's sails
the US government is convinced that
their allies across the Atlantic will
accept America with open arms we've made
some real progress technical progress
and now we need to draw that to a
conclusion and then there'll be a system
a system to monitor and measure to make
sure that we get the timing right then
we get the toggle switches right both
sides of the Atlantic want to get this
back up and both sides understand that
our economies depend on it the deep
important relation transatlantic
relationship matters harsh facts still
remain the European Union has banned all
non-essential travel from the United
States for all of its swagger and
self-proclaimed status in fighting kovat
the world is keeping its distance
America is isolated a pariah like never
before
Kalib Maupin RT New York
you